michael bloomberg has just pulled 13 and
14 percent in two national polls and
we've got to talk about what is the path
for michael bloomberg particularly if
the DNC dissatisfied with Joe Biden's
disastrous performance in Iowa decides
that maybe they want to change
establishment horses midstream so
remember the DNC changed the rules a few
days ago to at least potentially allow
Michael Bloomberg in two upcoming
debates despite the fact that he's not
accepting individual donors which up
until now had been a requirement to make
the debates he now needs 10 percent in
approved polls and incredibly 13 and 14
percent in two polls Bloomberg is in
third place either by himself or tied
with Elizabeth Warren in two polls now
morning consult from a couple of days
ago has it as Biden 28 Bernie 24 Warren
and Bloomberg tied at 14 and Pete Budaj
edged back at 6 then in the Harris Poll
you have Biden 31 Bernie 20 and
Bloomberg 13 one point ahead of
Elizabeth Warren of course statistically
within the margin of error this needs to
translate to votes right that's the
thing so that these numbers suggests to
me that indeed the DNC the DNC is going
to have to decide in their effort to
deny Bernie the candidacy and in light
of Joe Biden's poor performance in Iowa
do they want to get behind Pete Budaj
edge do they want to it seems less
likely but maybe get behind Amy
Klobuchar the other kind of
establishment centrist or do they want
to start looking at Michael Bloomberg
who of course has effectively an
unlimited amount of money to spend has
more than fifty five billion dollars
personally has already poured between
one and two hundred million into ads and
potentially would do a lot more if the
DNC were to get behind them behind him
but then what happens in individual
states that's also a question because
Bloomberg skipped Iowa and New Hampshire
barely a blip in Nevada South Carolina
almost not there
Bloomberg's focused on Super Tuesday so
you know
holding zero in Nevada but no polling
since January 11 maybe he could end up
doing better their polling 0 in South
Carolina but that poll is 10 days old in
California and Texas he's actually doing
something between 4 & 7 % the national
support will mean nothing unless he can
start accumulating delegates I said
before I think he may do it starting on
Super Tuesday but if he doesn't then
this will all be essentially for nothing
so where do you think Bloomberg's going
will the DNC get behind him do you feel
like you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that they're just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire non-fiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription
when you go to blankest comm slash
Pakman what blinka studs is take
thousands of popular non-fiction books
and condense them into either text or
audio that you can read or listen to in
just 15 minutes and what you get is all
of the most important ideas and
information from the book imagine being
able to listen to an entire nonfiction
book in the amount of time it takes you
to drive or walk home from work
I've just finished listening to upheaval
by Jared Diamond Jared Diamond a
tremendous author whose work I've
previously recommended excellent book
looking at some of modern history's
biggest national crises to figure out
how different countries ended up in such
precarious situations Blinky's has
totally transformed how I consume
information I love it of course I read a
book in its entirety when I can but
there are simply just so many books that
I want to read and would not have the
time for if it weren't for bling 'kiss
they have books on politics economics
philosophy science you name it you can
try it out yourself totally free for a
week and get 25% off if you decide to
subscribe just by going to blink is calm
slash Pakman I've put the link right
underneath this video like the rest of
us I bet you're going into 2020 thinking
about what you didn't get around to in
2019 and your goals for the new year if
you want to work towards being your best
self in 2020 understand more about the
world around you and make sure that your
time is well spent then blink astiz for
you